huh
all right so uh a nice win for us
uh yeah unfortunately yeah my internet
died for a second but
that's just uh how it is in croatia you
know
nothing you can do about it uh but yeah
i've restarted it so now it's uh
yeah it didn't continue to stream now
it's a new stream but you know what what
are you gonna do
yeah the internet is weird like that all
right so we are
almost approaching the second place if
we got that i think that would be our
finest achievement so far
so let's see if we can do it
okay and uh we we have some other titles
players that that
joined our quest for uh for the
top team we'll see we'll see how it goes
yeah the king was was from my dad yeah
all right mysterious expert that's quite
a mysterious handle
i like it
yeah it was weird because my internet
got depleted and then
the software that i'm using to stream
the obs the open broadcasting software
uh refused to connect even though i got
the internet back like the
you know the in a few seconds really
weird
yes panda knows best panda panda knows
best
it is it is all true it is all true
victor
all right
yeah uh there was a disconnect a a very
short one
unfortunately
all right but uh uh while we're not
doing that
a great uh internet wise we are doing
great point wise
cronaldinho why are you not in my team
that's a good question why why are you
not in my team
anyone anyone can join
greetings from minhan thank you thanks
for the contribution marco
yeah i know there were yeah it's really
weird yeah
uh youtube restarted the stream so you
know it's gonna
take a while to to get it back rolling
yeah gwen says it well the internet
service provider
failed to provide me with the service of
internet
all right so we're doing we're doing
well on time
and that knight is not happy where it is
so this is not happening the queen
covers that
all right this is gonna be
this is gonna be intense the light
square bishop is very strong and
[Music]
it's hard to say yeah very very passive
for the rook to be there
all right let's see if our mysterious
expert can pull this
off where is meadow meadow is
uh yeah mirrors behind me so you guys
can see him yeah he's right over there
yeah but he he's kind of keeping it
low-key
all right let's see let's see if
if we can win this one okay going for f7
very nice
it's probably gonna defend with the rook
no
he's gonna do it like this very very
brave
now queen h5 is queen h5 good here
can he go yeah he goes queen h5 very
nice
how does he stop this now
rook f8 only move
only only move but an insufficient one
then queen g6 i think we have this one
ah check yeah now now the queen covers
g6
okay so he he figured it out
all right very interesting very
interesting
yeah maybe maybe uh
once we once we finally move uh i will
try to do more
more live events so i might
be able to do like like a weekly thing
all right so we don't want to get
checkmated we have to take care of that
somehow that's not a free rook
in case anyone's wondering all right f3
very nice
and now the rook can either be captured
or it can't
root captures on g7 was go there was it
here rook captures and then what
i don't see a continuation this is
covered could be wrong
all right so we had a nice uh night
captures with
check we have to capture this because if
captures then made
and now now we have 15 seconds so
could could be anything
yeah meadow meadow ate the router made
with the router
he's a metals like that sometimes
all right we're winning but can we win
in 12 seconds
i would say yes i would say yes
huh
okay now now he he has to win even
though it's eight seconds
but who knows a rook is very strong
yeah the pawn is coming yeah that's it
very nice very nice threatening mate so
he has to move
all right four seconds is eternity for
for this guy
yeah we're good here very nicely done
very nicely done
all right so uh we're winning very
nicely but
we are not approaching second place
unfortunately
all right vitic is here all right let's
see if we take
from russia uh not playing not playing
currently
but it's not playing yeah we have some
title friends here
so let's see if we can if we can gain
some
we we haven't seen a single game from
them
yeah that that was a nice one
do i have uh a plan of uploading another
video of
my games uh i'm still yeah i do have a
quite a collection of my games
uh but you know when i start uploading
them it's gonna be
it's gonna be pretty wild i have one
that i'm particularly proud of
uh but that's all i'm going to mention
i might uh
might even upload it this sunday yeah
let's
let's do it on sunday i think that's
going to be i think that's going to be
great
yeah no no not tanaga mata saga maybe uh
maybe a few
few games
it is a game against who ah chronoldino
that's uh that's a secret
but you know you know the gentleman
do i drink wine not at the moment but
i've been known to
to drink a few cups yes
all right so what do we have here
all right we're doing we're doing well
black wants to keep the center closed
and he wants to push that
g5 pawn at some point but
we're not really letting him so
yeah this is gonna be this is gonna be
wild but we're very low on time
stay positive is almost on a 10 in a row
okay
we're checking next one stay positive
all right let's see
24 24 more seconds
all right how do you how do you break
through here can we get the queen
into the game no
okay
what now
huh
oh i thought he he's gonna push the pawn
okay
eight seconds i don't know
mate being threatened
yeah that's it oh that was a that was a
really really
good one uh congratulations electric
gold
we almost had it there yeah we had a
game by mysterious expert
uh where
is the one where is the one that's uh
almost on a 10 in a row
not sure i'm seeing him here
all right but let's check out uh someone
someone who's on a flame
all right this should be a good one he's
on a winning streak
diego alexander
no i do i do not i do not like
chavapsichi i
haven't i haven't eaten meat for some i
think like 18 years
otb chess in croatia at the moment uh
there are some events there are some
events
but i think it started started pretty
much everywhere
your castling rights were violated
yes max deutsch is the new alpha in
chess yes
no uh i've been a vegetarian for a very
long time i'm
i'm now vegan as uh
it requires more time and it's uh well
it's
more costly so now that i'm at that
point where i can afford it uh
uh for like maybe two years now maybe
year and a half two years now
how do you use the mongolian maneuver
opening i
don't think i've ever heard of that
that's uh that's a really that's a
really
you know a really big question
yeah i i i i'm gonna i'm gonna need you
to dumb this down for me
but thanks for the contribution uh mr a
fike
all right so we lost this one
unfortunately
uh we we tried to watch one who's on a
winning streak
all right uh this this game is already
close to an end
all right but this one is going on and
uh finlay is also on a winning streak
do i like dark souls i haven't played it
but i do like it but i i've seen uh i've
seen some speed runs and people
really destroyed that game you know like
really really nicely
yes mr mr barnes is the greatest you
you've said that well yes
no no none of my videos have german
titles it's just that
if you're from germany i think youtube
auto translates the titles for you in
german
if uh if someone already translated my
my videos you know the german titles in
german description
does meadow fart a lot uh well
what's a lot
they should add hikaru bots to dark
souls
yeah i'm i'm a fan of league of legends
uh but
uh you know you could say that i was a
fan
long long time ago probably up to maybe
season five
season four
yeah i yes i i am a candidate master in
croatia but not
internationally
how do you get my autograph well you
visit my hometown
we grab a beer and that's pretty much it
all right a very nice very nice check
here
but how do you how do you go on from
here
white will try to trade off this rook
and maybe bring the other rook into the
game but black of course will
prevent that from happening
yeah there was no good square for the
queen
i i i think
yeah it's not not gonna be easy bringing
that rook into the game
sven grabber whenever you are in in
zagreb
uh message me somehow and you know if
if i'm going to be able to i i never
turned down
a a nice beer or a game of chess
why would they add honestly karpov to
to dark souls
thoughts on nikhil in prague well there
is not
not much to be said about that they are
amazing players very very young talents
and
i think they can go very very far if
they if they persist
no no i'm not not american i'm from
croatia
do i play the guitar not actively i i
did some
well now or now already some 20 years
ago
ivanovic
what happened to misha i don't think oh
no fearless finley lost
every player we we checked that has a fl
flame uh loses all right okay this
has been going on for quite a while list
bro
winning streak let's wait for him to
start a game
lex friedman lex friedman in the chat
hey
do i enjoy analyzing and learning from
uh chess games played by ai
or are human games way more interesting
uh well
more more often than not human games are
way more interesting but
uh there were there was that instance
where
uh where deep mind trained alpha zero
and then alpha zero just you know
uh told us that we know absolutely
nothing about chess and how chess is
supposed to be played so that was like
uh
like an entire magical day when that
started happening but then after we got
used to it
uh we didn't really you know uh have all
that much to
to explore anymore they shut down alpha
zero and uh you know we just went on
with our lives but there
are some uh other projects that are
trying to emulate that like lately let's
just zero it's not
the same idea but uh they are
very interesting but of course uh human
games will always be
will always be more interesting at least
to me
and you know once uh once you start
analyzing computer games then you go to
human games you're like
what's this what are these guys doing
so although you know engines play much
better
humans human games are are for humans
oh that would be that would be a match
uh young
misha versus versus myself i don't know
i think misha would crush me
yes i i do have a game i consider my
mortal game
uh i still haven't shown it on the
channel i'm waiting for the right
opportunity
and finally a nice a nice victory for
our leader let's see let's see how we're
doing
still in third place i don't think we'll
be able to catch up to
to uh the second place but you know
uh i i didn't think we'd go all all that
uh far up the third place even so i'm
very very happy about that
all right let's check out someone from
below the
top 20 sharp chess player from from
where
from england alright let's let's check
it out
did i know slobodan mirkovich no no i
did not
no unfortunately i've never visited
india one of the
things that will uh will be rectified
in the future if at all possible
favorite player now i i don't know yeah
i do enjoy do both games immensely
but there are so many so many games and
players i enjoy
not the blue skull uh we are currently
fighting against other nine teams and we
are
uh you know playing with combined
strength
i don't think i would contribute all
that much why am i vegan
why why not
yes lex just tipped me yes lex is the
man
lex lex is the man he's he's a
workaholic but he's all right
great chess openings for black i don't
know the depends uh
against what against e4 i i really
enjoy the scandinavian but if you if
you've never like
seriously started anything start you
know you can start studying some
sicilian and you will
you will have a great time but i mean it
all depends you might enjoy the french
there are people who enjoy the french
g3n thanks a lot man
yeah a lot of people ask me that no i i
do not own it
i do not own it i i've sold it like i
think when it was 12k or something like
that
not just that i've actually bought uh
bought a few more
after i got that contribution and uh i
thought about keeping it but
then something came up i decided to you
know
take it out and you know what you're
gonna do but you can't really
think about it like that i mean uh you
either
uh you either never take it out or you
do take it out but
you know
thanks a lot for the contribution man
you are no longer intimidated by chess
i'm very very very glad to hear that
yeah yeah some people some people do
have that kind of approach to chess that
you're like yeah i shouldn't play it i'm
gonna lose like what
i mean how would you how would you play
anything you have to just you know enjoy
it
alright so our sharp chess player lost
unfortunately
but you know we can't win them all
okay raj not playing not playing all
right here we have a
uh here the queens are already off the
board uh
yeah here's a something could be
happening here
against julio julio is a is a winged man
to leach us
as you can see he has a nice wing uh to
his name
lex i love your work and passion for the
podcast please get eric back on soon
thanks for the great content agad matar
thank you
kitty
how can a person learn blindfold chess
uh well you just play it
like just play it and that's it
you you will be able to do it you know
but you have to of course know the
squares
what does the wing mean the wing means
that you are a contributor
to to leeches uh either by contributing
on a monthly basis or doing a one-time
contribution
or you know in in any way helping
leeches function
as it's a completely free platform so
they only exist
due to people having this wing next to
their name
do i regret showing most of the best
games ever played in my early years in
youtube no not at all i i plan on
covering them
uh all in uh you know uh for full hd
at 60 frames per second or no full hd
uh i think they are all in full hd it
would be more of a
more of a maybe 4k thing yeah
at some point yeah
yeah the good stuff is back tonya
wishing you a happy birthday no i don't
play on twitch
i do stream sometimes but nah uh very
rarely stream chess i i did stream some
zelda
uh but i don't i don't have all that
much time to to really practice
zelda i was really trying to speedrun it
but
it's i mean i i am able to do it but
it's just very very hard
uh but now that i when i finally move i
will have a
more you know uh uh well an easier
time uh regarding streaming so i might
be able to do a bit more
i know you guys are interested in that
uh you guys are only interested in chess
i imagine but
uh you know it's a it's a pretty pretty
fun game
yeah i've tried i've tried dota i've
never
never actually been able to play it i've
tried it like once or twice
didn't really stick with me
how much time do i invest in youtube
chess bits uh
pretty much all of it
yeah speed running is amazing content i
i didn't mean spin
speed running itself but you know the
the
the choice of the game
yeah thanks for the contribution and uh
no no the king is just
i i enjoy showing it because uh like
when i have those
five seconds when i give you guys time
to think uh
i don't know i i enjoy doing something
so when i saw that i could show you the
skin i could show you some other stuff i
have like a lot of stuff here
uh i don't know i i thought it was funny
and people
always think stuff like that is weird so
you know i thought why not
uh mario kart alright here's some sort
of a wicked end game a bishop
pair versus a rook let's see how those
bishops
destroy the rook pedro vitor thanks for
the contribution man
all right let's see
how long it will take for for the
bishops to overcome him
yeah i don't know about the exact time
uh that uh i'm moving uh i'm moving to
the other the other house but uh should
be like
within a month like worst case scenario
yeah really
eric is playing all right we will show
eric's game
he came too late if eric was with us
from the beginning we would we would
certainly win this
yeah i do accept challenges on leeches
outside of stream times but
mostly bullet yeah i very rarely play
anything but bullet
all right why
is the oh okay
yeah this is weird wow something
something got lagged out with the board
it's very interesting um
yeah you guys sure eric is playing
[Music]
because it doesn't uh it doesn't show
yeah
really weird
huh yeah and it it doesn't show
him to be street oh yeah he's actually
playing yeah he just
jumped into 50. all right and he's on a
winning streak okay we will show we will
show a game
okay
all right let me just yeah i don't think
he's currently
in any games
yeah okay all right let's let's check
out eric eric's game
yeah of course it's possible that i've
blundered my queen
yeah if we played that is that is a
possibility yeah
which eric the the peaceful one
all right
i know of many languages but i i only
speak one
all right okay two if you count if you
count english
yeah i actually don't know the game uh
wesley versus eugenio torre
alright so how do we how do we proceed
here
eric not doing great on time but he did
berserk
so he's trying to win points for us but
also
save time very nice very nice
why evan's gambit is the greatest i
don't know it
is some things just r you know
morphe saga is taking too long how can
it be taking too long
morphe saga happens when everything else
is on hold and uh you know always
all right so our knight is hanging but
we saved it
all right eric saves the knight so what
now g4 is coming
oh it's gonna be it's gonna be crazy
panda you lost to a cheater i'm very
sorry to hear that
horns apollo yeah i i thought so too but
you know
some people really didn't enjoy enjoy my
joke for a april fool's day i have no
idea why
all right now now eric should win
but he's down to 25 seconds but eric is
super fast so
i think he'll be able to do it
uh sort of yeah my binance issue
was not sorted out just yet but uh
i guess it's like that for everyone so
it should be
should be sorted out okay of course you
resigned this there is now completely
winning
six pawns is enough for any man good
game eric all right
let's see how all right 15 more minutes
in the tournament and we are still in
third place
uh i imagine we will remain there but
you
we could drop the fourth which is also
great i think the best we got was
like maybe sixth or seventh so far
so this is really really awesome
uh all right let's see let's see
meraki
eric is on a roll yeah if eric uh if
eric came sooner
we might even have a chance of winning
this
yeah i don't think he would resign being
down okay that's a that's a sacrifice
right there we of course
no yeah that knight here is too
dangerous of a defender
dude i am from croatia
hmm
[Music]
yeah i'm pretty sure eric had his own
team but i guess he couldn't make it
that uh to play from the beginning so
uh i think he just like uh started
streaming now maybe or he's
planning to so he joined us for for a
few games which is very
very nice of him
yeah when the knights on f8 there is no
mate
that's that's how it goes
yeah eric is super i am all right so we
won this one very nicely oh this was
savage wow
that was that was really really really
something
uh all right who do we have that we
haven't seen yet
t-zipper we've seen smartypants chess uh
all right there there's action on the
board we can check this one out
yeah i i don't think there's a time
where where when there isn't a drama in
chess
i think that's you know chess comes
comes with drama
genuine regards from hungary thank you
christian
and from scotland tons
62
have i ever met anand or carlson or
anish giri in person
yes i've met all three of them when they
were in croatia for the
croatian great for the grand chester
that happened in croatia
and uh you have i don't know if you've
seen it i have it on my instagram
account uh they i brought a chess board
for all of them to sign so they they all
signed it and
i have a like a board with all of their
signatures
so that was nice well not all of them i
didn't get a signature from wesley so
but what are you gonna do
branchoimera there you go man hope hope
it was
it was okay
all right what do we have here that that
pawn is nicely protected
so we have to get around that somehow
uh the candidates tournament resumes now
in in a few days
have i ever been threatened by hikaru no
why why would i
why would that happen and how would that
happen
yeah i am uh i think magnus is
i think of all of them magnus is the
tallest but yeah i think i am taller
than
all of them
did i ever have opponents in tournaments
being rude to me when they lost
yeah uh actually yes i had a i had a
game
against uh candidate master here in
croatia and uh
uh when i defeated him he said
uh i will not congratulate you because
you
you you were breathing very loudly and i
was like what
and he said i was breathing very loudly
and that it was very disturbing to him
no i'm actually not that tall i don't
know why people bring that up i'm like
191 191
is anish the most savage grandmaster
tweeter
i i would say yes i i don't think you
know the others are
improving and they are learning but
you know yeah just stop breathing yeah
all right
yeah but i think it was just because he
was he was a bit higher rated than me
and uh you know some people really
really don't know how to how to lose
yeah i should have said sorry about that
and fixed my breeding volume
all right so we're not grabbing that
pawn
but we are breaking through the center
okay is this one of those cases where
the bishop
uh destroys both rooks we will see
captures and we kinda wanted that one
okay now it's a free pawn
and now we're winning because there's
simply not enough time for our opponent
so hooray
no i've i've actually tried valorant and
i'm not not not a big fan
not a big fan i have to say but you know
no in no way you know any
anyone to put standards on these things
i i just don't
they didn't think it was very enjoyable
i i thought that they could maybe make
and make it a little bit better but i'm
way too old for such games
you know okay varade is here let's let's
see if varad
will be able to get a game
you know last uh last first person first
person shooter i really enjoyed was like
quake i think it was quake quake
3 arena or something like that
ah when will we hear a news of max
deutsch becoming a number one tetris
player i don't know i i've heard that it
takes him like a month
to really master stuff and then a bit
more
uh you know to to fully you know destroy
the world elite what chronologino says
that we are in second place
carlson versus karpov at 2008 tom
memorial blitz amazing attacking game by
young magnus
are you saying i haven't covered that
well i there is there is a chance yes
there are some games that i still
haven't covered
that that is true
yeah everyone says i'm i'm a tyrion size
and unfortunately our good friend varad
loses
and we are indeed in second place wow
this is uh this is beyond incredible i
didn't think this was possible
all right so now well now our appetites
are really starting to you know grow
because if we can get second you know
what that means of course
that means we can try and get second
again
no but seriously okay we're we're not
even close to first place but i i didn't
think we'd be able to get second wow
this is incredible comeback of the
century
all right so who do we who we have
brothelo from russia all right
let's check out bruteello
doing good work for our team charlie how
does one join the team oh yeah for those
of you who just joined the chat
or you know are new here uh there is a
link in the description below that takes
you to the tournament and
a link below that one uh takes you to
our
uh team uh i think it's some
uh it was some eighteen thousand players
today so i think it's around that
uh maybe even a bit more now and
you can always join one more
eric game all right we'll see if eric
has a game going
yes we we can do that
who is the best bullet player aside from
magnus you mean
i have not yet been promoted to dad
officially will still be some two
to three months but yeah thank you
what's the most shiny object in our new
house
oh that's uh that's a good one i i don't
think we have anything
shiny i don't think we have anything
shiny
like the maybe the windows they are nice
and clean now so maybe the windows
yeah ahmed i was uh i was very much into
astrophysics when i was younger really
read a lot about it in high school but
you know
time time passes on and you don't really
follow up on what's what's been
happening but uh if you follow the
previous stream a good friend of mine
is uh has a doctorate in astrophysics
and
uh well i do hang out with him from time
to time whenever i get uh the
opportunity
and uh well it's always always very
enjoyable
all right can we do this brothelo
e5 what is e5 wow that's he he wants to
win on time i like
no no he blundered mate
oh but there was yeah i mean
what are you gonna do all right let's
see if eric all right eric has a nice
nice beefy position uh let's check it
out he's playing against don
shock who is a pirate wow i did not know
you could be a pirate in in
leeches wow you can actually be a pirate
wow okay i'm definitely switching mine
from from croatia to a pirate
wow you can be a pirate nice
yeah wow that's that's nice
yeah we do have some names in mind uh
but you know we will we will still keep
them uh very
very private yeah i did imagine t-ball
would be a pirate yeah
i'm gonna try to apply to be a pirate as
well i don't know if it's like a super
secret leeches society thing
or can anyone just be a pirate i don't
know
could young frog would be a world
championship challenger yeah
could be
yeah i know you can always be a penguin
in antarctica
yeah i'm gonna change my name to agat
mately
[Laughter]
i got meti yeah
yeah i have to get a parrot uh i don't
know i don't know if
the elena would allow me to have a
parrot uh
no i i really i i constantly try and
make time to play like
at least one game of league but uh you
know never
never get around to it i was just you
know improving in my tryndamere top
but you know just can't can't find the
time for it
all right let's see can can eric do this
he's up a pawn not for long
yeah but he berserks every game he
berserks every game
alright so this is our equal game i
imagine eric will try to flag him
even though he's still lower on time
yeah i would visit kiev yeah i mean i
would visit
every everywhere if i could parrots can
live for up to 50 years
that's great so he's like uh
like a lifetime companion parrot
just what a pirate needs
i don't imagine pirates lived very long
so it probably means that
their parrots always outlived them
yeah i'm pretty sure you have to collect
the pirates norm first you know
i mean it'd be silly if they allowed
anyone to just
you know join the the the rank of pirate
i i i i like alpha zero more than
stockfish i
that's not even the the the same you
know
the same level
i haven't stopped uh putting uh uh
arabic
subtitles to my videos someone else was
doing it and i guess
i guess they stopped all right and a
nice draw
a draw by insufficient material the
greatest of all draws
all right so did the
did the event finish yeah i'm pretty
sure it did
why didn't we hear the sound isn't there
like always the sound like
or something like that
yeah or yeah none of the games okay
yeah i guess they wait for all the games
to finish okay there's there are still
some games
going on yeah the draw of draws
is calling arbiters oh no
all right i think uh i think we after
this one i think then
then the event is officially over
nice one eric next time join us join us
from the beginning
and why why weren't you
uh in a team of your own
am i drunk no unfortunately not
all right so let's see five more seconds
for for chess meraki i don't think this
uh this can go our way
gula pop is uh second individually and
our best player
nice
yeah that is what i'm that is what i
thought eric
thank you thank you for for joining us
and uh and berserking all of the games
thanks for the contribution man but i
don't think i'll be i'll be in split
at that time that's on the other far
side of croatia than where i'm from
yeah okay this was actually very close
uh considering uh
chesmaraghi had only a few seconds
so that's it that's it for the
tournament uh
let's just check out our team page yeah
okay okay we've jumped nicely from 18
000
members we are now officially over 20
000 members in our team
so that's uh very nice even though the
only the top 20
who perform the the best are accounted
for
you know for the final score still very
very impressive and we
got second place just you know uh by
a four point margin and as panda said
uh from germany second overall player
and
the top player of our team and the the
top scorers are
mysterious expert brotello uh arshad
modak uh
uh wow i can't even read this pravyar
voc
uh cvk jaden uh international master
mario kart chess meraki fearless finlay
matoya sparkle97 varad 45
tactician finest taylor pearson
kais 88 jaeger jaegerman uh losing
tactics robbie
in 932 uh 3003
gorkham yar and everyone else who
who who played for us uh here so very
very
nicely done and uh yeah yeah i mean it's
it's two hour event but it really passes
on quite quickly
and i still can't believe that we got
second place this is
uh this is beyond my wildest
expectations so really really thank you
for that and
uh uh yeah i will we'll see you in the
in the next one
and uh it was really really really
enjoyable
uh chaitanya kukarni thanks for the
contribution and uh
who do i think will win the candidates
uh i don't know like it's it's a really
tough question and i'm not rooting for
every anyone
because whoever wins will put up a
really really
awesome fight for you know against
magnus
yeah colonel dino i don't know why you
why we haven't played i mean that's
really not cool you're you know the the
moderator and everything you you should
play
but uh what are you gonna do
all right so that's it for this one guys
uh we'll be
it's it's really late here so i'm gonna
i'm gonna tune in but
uh like i said once we're once we
complete moving and once i set up my new
studio in
in the in the new house then i'll be
streaming
a lot more often than we can you know
get a lot more games in and uh
even just you know playing against
subscribers not even doing any events or
something like that
uh been a while since we did something
like that uh but yeah
that's it uh if you haven't seen today's
video do check it out other than that
uh see you soon guys